estas imágenes provienen de los propios
batallones chechenos las tropas
acostumbradas a la guerra urbana están
en el centro de Mario Pony disparando A
discreción el ejército ruso ha pasado a
la ofensiva tras rodear la ciudad
durante más de tres semanas
todavía hay focos de resistencia los
residentes que se escondían en los
refugios se están rindiendo vamos a
evacuar a todos contra el armario Paul
el último Puerto en el mar de azoff con
presencia ucraniana permitiría a Rusia
conectar sus fuerzas en crimea al oeste
con sus tropas en la región del dumbas
al este
un potencial punto de inflexión en la
guerra durante varias semanas la ciudad
estuvo sitiada bombardeada sin descanso
desde el aire
el enemigo ha construido allí una
defensa aérea muy fuerte tanto en la
Aviación desde crimea como por tierra
Por eso no hay actualmente una solución
militar para mariupon pueden acusarme a
mí a la oficina presidencial al
presidente personalmente etcétera Pero
no
esto ha empujado aún a más gente a
escapar a la estación de tren del beef a
1200 kilómetros de distancia llegan cada
día más refugiados de Mario Paul como
esta mujer de 86 años que se cayó
mientras estaba en un refugio acompañada
de su nieta
Hay personas muertas tiradas por ahí y
nadie que las recoja alguien debe
intervenir la ciudad está siendo borrada
de la faz de la tierra no hay nada vivo
todas las carreteras están bombardeadas
hay árboles arrancados de raíz es como
una película de terror
pero salir de la ciudad es difícil los
corredores humanitarios Solo han
permitido que 9000 personas
abandonaranriopol el viernes